one of your hobbies is quite dangerous
you're really into rock climbing yeah
and we got these pictures you are
serious about rock climbing this is you
I mean first of all this is a very
dangerous sport
and I don't know if anyone's told you
that but you know do you get frightened
when you're up there and these
incredible I mean you're with a friend I
think who can actually ascend without
ropes is that yeah that's actually true
that that is that's Alex Honnold right
there he just climbed El Cap and
Yosemite without a rope which is about
3,000 feet tall it's it's 3 Empire State
building's high and he climbed it
without a rope he's the first person to
ever do that but yeah you get scared I
mean it's it's it's pretty intense but
it's also beautiful and it's really fun
and it's exciting you would be amazing
on the wall because you you're
incredibly long
[Music]
[Laughter]
with that give me your laugh
Jared I don't know why you're laughing
and churning away but I am I am long but
you need a lot of upper-body strength
that might be a problem do you know you
look really fit and then strong okay I
was very afraid what do you do when you
knows moments when yours you're there
and you're clinging to the rock and you
don't know how you're gonna take the
next step and you might fall what's
going through your head death usually
some prayers yeah
but but you know you do have ropes and
it is a very safe thing to do if you do
it correctly and and and and luck is on
your side I would do it if I was with a
very good climber yeah and I was in a
baby bjorn that he was where I was
strapped to his chest and I had a juice
box and he was going up and he was just
limply hanging then I'll do it if you
can set that up I'll be there absolutely
you